it's monday happy monday reject nation
that's what monday means yes mondays are
spooky
spooky mondays spookiest day of the week
five really scary ghost videos
i warned you from nukes top five
let's see he's probably right he usually
[Music]
is
unexpected cameo this next video might
be one of the most bizarre clips i've
ever posted
not because japanese students walking
around
japanese video was filmed as a tv
documentary about a typical
japanese high school this video shows an
average school class day starting with
english lessons
[Music]
[Music]
but later in the video during a japanese
literature class
things just got totally bizarre what the
hell
is that just some student chillin
it looks as if a girl is sitting on the
windowsill outside the fourth floor
classroom
however there's no balcony outside this
classroom window
[Music]
[Applause]
no no
no i call [ __ ] no i can't do this
has disappeared so is this a ghost
calling camera in a legit japanese high
school documentary
or is it all just an elaborate hoax
that's a damn good hoax chris
ain't pray to no ghost facebook user
chris adams says that he's lived in a
haunted house for years
oh how do you top that top one
in a nearby fire jesus chris claims that
he's become so
used to the bizarre supernatural
activity in his house
that it no longer even scares him late
one night chris wakes up to the sound of
small
footsteps in the hallway almost as if a
child is running through the house
but chris is home alone
and begins recording
wait
he has a kid or doesn't i
because a bunch of kids toys
maybe their offerings
to entice the child
it seems that someone or something throw
a mop bucket across chris's bathroom for
he remains calm and goes to check it out
and good white guy even stranger
no no
no oh my god
thanks for helping me find this
that is terrifying
[Music]
that is so scary
holy crap
right here right now
something seems to move the shower
curtain some viewers even believe that a
face can be seen
through the curtain i love how
christophe
how annoyed he was
poor movie crap
it's still going
that that like when you see it so
there's definitely moving
unless i'm wrong i believe
oh huh
you [ __ ] serious
turned out that the noise chris hears
was the same
bucket oh my gosh
and his facebook friends confirm it
chris says that he's never managed to
catch anything on camera
before this but what do you think
let me know down in the comments below i
i i love just
his attitude towards the whole thing the
next videos are from the mysterious
youtube channel
that was pretty much man isn't it
in short 11 second clips since 2015
youtubers have been dissecting this
channel and its videos to try to
determine
if this is a so-called quote haunted
youtube channel
are simply an arg and no one
has ever figured it out in this video
the guys are hanging out
when this happens
a loud bang can be heard on the door
leading to the garage
and the guys are more than a little
freaked out
dude like holy
my camera's off dude the screen's like
completely black dude
no it's completely black oh it's not in
the window yeah
yeah dude it's completely black
it's like a white
as they enter and then quickly moves
away
none of them seem to have seen the face
and they just shrug off the incident
[Applause]
almost a year later and another bizarre
paranormal video post appears on the
snch
channel this time the guys are hanging
out again
playing monopoly they're right
every time we play this guy game you're
not gonna play an alliance together and
we're not going
to know it's monopoly you can do that
you can't
[Music]
what are you doing
just got ripped off
now there's a lot happening here
supposedly some supernatural presence is
ripping doors off hinges and cutting the
lights
but we'll never know what happened here
what do you mean i'm dead and nothing
new has been posted in over three years
are you
kidding me check out the snch
channel and explore the mystery on your
own there are still plenty of weird
videos to be found
ugh
what i don't know if they know i'm
looking or they know i'm like oh
oh oh [ __ ] there's two
they're knocking wait wait
maybe she is in trouble
you guys sound like dicks if there's
someone in trouble yeah
so was the snch channel mysterious quote
haunted youtube channel
that just suddenly ended or is it all a
failed arg
you decide watcher
simply enough this video shows some
friends i catch in front of a lockdown
abandoned building
but things take an odd turn best place
to play
[Music]
[Music]
manager yeah of course says the
building's been empty for years
they all head upstairs to see who's
hiding inside the locked house
hell yeah really
[Music]
just look
wow
some youtube viewers believed that the
video might be a hoax
but others argued that the ghoulish face
and the man's odd movements just
don't seem to what
what do you think weirdly looks better
when they blow it up you see a video
that you think should be featured on the
top five or if you capture something
spooky yourself
might be one of those like crazy kids
who goes to the school
yes top five
as always thanks for watching like
what's the
what's the time we timelines are
important yeah how many minutes was it
until they got up there
yeah did they leave to go find someone
and then come back
you know this guy escaped timelines are
important having successfully
pranked another group of tourists i'm
skimming this again
i only see okay wait there's a pin
comment here from nukes top five
number five new can't count for those
wondering what happened in number five
i would never feature someone's video
who do not want to post it whether it's
fair use or not the original video
number five featured an alleged ghost
running by a child's door i posted the
video because the compression of the
video made the child's face
unrecognizable and since i was analyzing
the video the video was protected under
fair use okay the original video is also
public and shared on several social
media sites it was sent into me by a
viewer with good intentions
however oh no the child's parents who
posted the original video did not
appreciate some of the youtube comments
it did not wish for the video to remain
public
so i removed the video clip to respect
their wishes my sincere apologies
here's the link to leave a comment to
that video
get that video taken down on that
channel
uncomfortable comments this is why we
can't have knives i was like wow what a
nice guy
you know with a total dick moving
yeah yeah now go give him hell
i respect that yeah there's some videos
that a couple i could think of that i've
reacted to in the past that i was like
you know i just don't want to make
entertainment out of this particular
ones that bring times over guests and i
don't i stop filming halfway through i'm
like not this scary video ghosts and
stuff are fun
yeah there have been times so i get it
let's talk about the ones that are
featured in here all of these
were scary all of these were really
scary like this
this is the best most consistent i don't
know if it's the scariest one we've seen
from nukes top five but it's the most
consistent in terms of four out of four
yeah yeah you never know what that one
was because that first one a
it's gonna sound so bad j-horse scares
the crap out of me this seems like
something out of jail
yes because this is japanese school
design the girl with the hair like it
just seems like something out of jr and
j
[ __ ] have conditioned me to understand
that nothing good
happens in a japanese classroom that's
where ghosts
live that's where they go to torment you
the way it was
captured where was the footage coming
from because a lot of times the
it's the questioning of things that make
me really suspicious is this someone who
took the raw footage and then put it up
on some separate channels the people
putting together the documentary
noticed this later on while they were
filming because and then we're like we
could go viral
yeah it's when you're filming stuff
especially when you're behind the camera
you're so focused on what you need to
capture which in this moment is the
students in the classroom that you're
probably not even aware of
the window oh yes there's something like
really moving outside you know you could
probably just look like another head in
the background yeah then when they do
the exterior shot
you see that there's no way there's like
a balcony and there's nothing about
someone
falling off of a building how did that
person get there i call
real ghost adventurous real ghost
because that ghost would have had to
like climb
a few stories exactly perch on a window
and i wonder why this ghost chose this
particular class
is it about the classroom is it a
particular student who's the viewer
it's the view it's the view here it goes
yeah look at that's beautiful
that's pretty crazy and like no one's
paying attention to her i know and
they're
like at least the kids like right next
to the window
you would think or maybe it's like you
know maybe
they're just used to that ghost maybe
yeah
yeah if they just bothered to ask they'd
be like oh yeah that's our bud the dude
in the home
with the sliding bucket this one seems
so real
especially when the shower curtain bit
starts to happen like the
timing is is really good because he's
just kind of fumbling around he seems
annoyed the way you get when you're kind
of scared
and then yeah when the the shower
curtain starts to just tuft inward
as so chilling i mean his attitude i
love
because it sounds like someone who's
been dealing with this crap for so long
and it's just fed up with it it's
freaking like like this is my property
to leave
you know like that kind of attitude like
scary
bothering me like it doesn't even seem
like if that if i saw that
with a curtain i would shut that door
lock it
call the cops right away there is no
chance
yeah there's no chance in hell i'm
opening that curtain
i would just shut that door locked and
be like there's no way they're getting
out i'm calling the cops
i was gonna say brave soul going in
there like batting the shower curtain
back and forth i'm like you don't make
this thing mad
even if it is a child i mean from
watching it it's all in one take
when that happens yeah now that is
either just like incredible effects
because i'm slowing this down i don't
see anyone in the bathtub
maybe maybe maybe there's a hidden cut
when he grabs onto the curtain and the
camera's really moving but
i gotta say man this is like everything
around it seems very real
it looks very very tangible and very
authentic
and even yeah just like the little uh
nudge extra where the bucket kind of
follows him out of the room and
everything like
yeah that one really chilled me
especially because it feels like you're
just standing in the room with him
yeah the ones with the the dudes that's
like my favorite kind of
i love this one just because we're just
a bunch of bros who are just trying to
have a bro
channel and they just keep having scary
crap happening
and their reactions to it seems so
authentic too that was my favorite just
listening to them be like i don't want
to go to you
and then finally the one guy goes he's
like you're so brave right now bro
you're so brave
it's like the opposite of everything i
would have come to expect and it was
very
refreshing in that way but even when
they're playing monopoly like
to fake something like this you got to
just be damn good actors because the
thing where you can
go wrong in in so many cases with
putting a hoax like this
is you could tell the person in front of
the camera or is being recorded is
anticipating something to happen and
then the way they're reacting to it's
like oh yeah you're clearly anticipating
this and the way you're behaving but
these guys seem so like just dudes who
got a house together like hey it looks
like some fun youtube channel
and it's just scary crap keeps happening
they got in way over their heads and
that's actually
i really like the ones that come with a
here's a channel and they post this kind
of thing and then it just
stops yeah three years ago because that
totally just enhances the mystery
altogether of like if it's a viral prank
show excellent job if it's real i hope
they're not
dead because that last clip i was scared
for them because you can't see
anything and that's the thing is you
know it's that old classic horror movie
theme of like it's it's way scarier when
you can't see it so when you're just in
there with the dark and them
trying to figure it out yeah it's
chilling
i hope they're not dead maybe they were
greeted by the ghosts and they told them
to stop
putting up videos and stuff we don't
want to be viral that last one
i know it just seems like such a horror
movie type of thing it looks
very ghostly feels a little too
cinematic
yeah i could see this one being beated
out and timed i mean the one thing is
this is the only clip i think i've seen
zooming in made it feel more authentic
to me yeah yeah like the
the crispness of the image like from
afar when you're looking at the long
shot it does
kind of look like oh an added element or
something and then when they zoom in it
looks just like a pale guy who's like
lurking which is creepy in and of itself
i guess
but the movement was the the scariest
part of that for me
there's this cut here like it looks like
they really got what like the dean or
something to
yeah groundskeeper or whatever the way
they're
behaving sounds very realistic i think
there's someone
there it's hard to say that's a ghost
because they lost
[ __ ] yeah because you a kid could break
in there
hide out there maybe this could be a
loner dude and he just hired you know
from other movies i've seen
chill in there and you'd be hiding right
now like you'd be either gonna be in the
building
he could just be hiding in there you
could just be a vagrant guy just in
their spray paintings
yeah yeah and uh you know squatting or
whatever and the girl kept saying i have
it on camera have it on camera
the way she was saying it was making it
sound as if the person they had
get them in there didn't even see the
footage i feel like it'd just be an
entirely different case
if it was like look we got it on camera
the dean was like whoa
someone's in the building you know yeah
who is that why don't you guys wait here
while i go get security yeah
yeah yeah it would have been a very
different type of
mood i believe they got some high
profile guys at school to get them in
there
it would have been a different kind of
mood when they're going up the stairs i
think yeah think about these things
get better at your viral spooky video
random
british people still creepy still creepy
though very creepy
all right guys which one of these four
scared you the most make sure to
subscribe to nukes top five you haven't
done so already subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get notified whenever you got a youtube
video up leave a comment about
which other channels do you recommend
for us to check out along these lines
last but not least
shouting out someone today whose
birthday it was yesterday
unfortunately i know this is not the
kind of video she'd be watching
but hey let's give it a shot happy
birthday rosa para happy birthday to you
happy birthday to you happy birthday
dear who
rosa happy birthday
to you you and many more
and so much more too much you're going
to be sick or you're going to be so sick
of winning you'll be so sick of your
birthdays
eventually you're gonna get so old and
die
from having too many birthdays you gotta
stop that
people wanna know what's this key to
immortality
don't celebrate your birthday don't
acknowledge it it doesn't count
so rosa that's my gift to you this is
the last birthday you should celebrate
the one in 2020
[Laughter]
forever young i'm just kidding i love
you rosa thank you so much for being you
lady stark
and i hope you had a great one with the
family keep kicking asses here
and haunting our hearts